bonjour à toutes et à tous ici votre art
rock nationale et bienvenue pour cette
vidéo simple sans prise de tête est fait
avec le coeur avengers endgame sort dans
moins de trois jours et j'ai besoin
personnellement de revenir un peu sur le
film et vous parler de mes attentes qui
se crée depuis infinity ward nous sommes
clairement pour moi sur le film de
l'année voire de la décennie
c'est comme si c'était la fin évidemment
c'est une vidéo totalement personnelle
et subjective
vous avez l'habitude que je vous le dise
mais il est important de le préciser
je vous invite quant à vous à partager
vos attentes
est ce que vous aimeriez voir dans le
film dans le plus grand des respects
bref
commençons tout d'abord j'attends
beaucoup du personnage de thanos nous le
savons tous danos va forcément perdre
face aux avengers et être en difficulté
et c'est là ma crainte c'est quelque
chose de tout à fait naturel chez des
êtres vivants si vous êtes mal en point
si vous êtes contrarier vous allez
répliqué presque automatiquement par la
violence pour moi thanos et le meilleur
méchant qui existent car il n'est pas du
tout pour moi un méchant en fait nous ne
sommes pas sur quelqu'un qui tue par
plaisir qui veut juste le mal thanos
bien qu extrême dans ses paroles et
surtout ses actes souhaite relancer la
vie du moins c'est ce qui est fortement
montré dans une finity war si vous
revoyez le film thanos ne tue que pour
accomplir la mission qu'il s'est
attribuée il tue que par nécessité
voyez comment ils épargnent tout le
monde wakanda ce serait
vraiment une déchirure pour moi que
thanos sous la difficulté deviennent une
grosse brute sans cervelle qui veut
massacrer tout le monde
le titan est un cérébral est une sorte
de philosophe
j'attends de lure échanges avec les
avengers qu'ils les fassent même douter
par rapport à annuler son plan bon là
j'avoue c'est moi qui ai un peu extrême
mais j'espère que vous comprenez l'idée
thanos est un visionnaire comme tony
stark très belles transitions tiens en
parlant de tony tony est le père des
avengers et peut-être même le plus
important les réalisateurs avaient
expliqué la raison sur pourquoi
thanos connaît tony et elle est très
légitime
tony essaye de prévenir les dangers il a
voulu concevoir vision rennes pour ça à
la base il est je pense le personnage le
plus complexe des avengers dans sa
manière de penser et d'agir pour faire
liaison à ce site owni a été sauvé par
le dr strange qui connaît la seule et
unique façon de vaincre thanos je vous
le répète depuis maintenant un an mais
si tony a été sauvé par strange alors
que c'était contre ses principes
ckx était nécessaire et justement je
veux un face à face avec thanos un
échange entre lui et le titan sur les
enjeux du claquement de doigts l'univers
en général mais surtout voir
l'importance de tony par rapport au plan
du docteur le voir prendre le leadership
des opérations et trouver le plan
complexe qui permettrait d'arriver à la
victoire
concernant l'affrontement ultime car il
est évident que thanos et les avengers
vont en venir aux mains à un moment je
vous avoue que j'ai une sorte de rêve
par rapport à ça et qui a été teasé dans
les trailer pour moi ce film sera très
symbolique concernant tout le mca il
faut que ça pue l'émotion à plein nez
pour moi je souhaite réellement un
combat final entre thanos et tony steve
accompagné de tort les trois avengers
les plus importants du mc les trois
piliers de l'univers cinématographique
de marvel rien ne me ferait plus vibrer
qu'un combat où nous voyons les trois
héros réuni seul face à la noce pour le
vaincre et accentuer leur complicité qui
dure depuis des années
vous allez certainement me dire mais
pourquoi tu ne veux pas un affrontement
de thanos face à tous les héros revenus
du claquement de doigts et bien pour moi
ce serait gâcher la scène de la défaite
de thanos nous sommes clairement
sur le endgame et pour moi les héros
disparus n'ont pas intervenir endgame
tracera l'histoire des avengers restants
et quoi de plus symbolique que les trois
piliers des avengers pour défaire la
noce j'ai très peur d'une fin à la super
smash bros brawl vous ce serait le
bordel tellement y aurait deux
personnages le crossover ultime tous les
héros réunis pour vaincre l'ennemi
principal et voir le soleil se lever par
la suite je détesterais vraiment ça il
est très clair que pour moi si ngame
doit marquer les esprits et devenir le
film ultime
il nous faut une fin douce amère comme
dirait le créateur de game of thrones il
est sûr que la victoire sera totale
mais à quel prix nous sommes sur une fin
avec une note bien sombre des héros au
bout du rouleau est prêt à se sacrifier
pour marquer à jamais au fer rouge les
mémoires des fans des héros doivent
mourir ou au moins un très important
steve rogers c'est pour moi l'exemple
parfait le soldat prêt à se sacrifier au
combat depuis son arrivée et qui souffre
de ne plus être à son époque depuis le
début la mort de toni serait pour moi la
plus marquante mais plus on avance plus
je doute le personnage est beaucoup trop
important or film pour que marvel se
permettent de le tuer néanmoins
j'attends quelques morts bien choquant
histoire qu'on se rappelle à jamais du
chapitre final endgame enfin il faut
pour moi une ouverture marvel va
continuer les marvel par la suite de
nouveaux héros sont arrivés et d'autres
vont faire leur entrée
nous savons que les x-men arriveront
aussi un jour tout comme les quatre
fantastiques
bref nous devons évoluer et tourner la
page
je veux que la fin et surtout la scène
post générique amène une ouverture et
signe totalement la fin du mc eu depuis
que nous le connaissons on passe à la
phase 4
quand même c'est pas rien il faudrait
nous montrer des héros qui par exemple
rangerait leurs costumes je pense par
exemple à hawk eye qui voudra très
certainement arrêter son activité pour
profiter à fond de sa famille ou encore
tony qui pourrait prendre le contrôle du
shield est resté aux côtés de pepper
sans avoir à mettre le costume d'iron
man ou des exils par exemple qu'on ne
reverra plus certains héros avant un
moment
je pense beaucoup à tort qui pourrait
rebâtir un nouvel as garde de son côté
et qui reprendrait l'héritage de son
père au détriment de
oui les héros sur terre il faut aussi
pour moi détruire pour mieux rebâtir je
pense par exemple au qg des avengers ou
encore le nom même des avengers que tout
ça s'arrête et devienne autre chose je
serait même prête à imaginer que les
prochains avengers auront un tout autre
nom et donc pas d'abord 5
bref j'attends du risque du changement
une fin captain marvel aura aussi son
rôle à jouer
et dieu sait qu'elle sera importante
tout comme banner il est temps que le
personnage évolue et devienne enfin le
héros que nous attendons tous n'hésitez
pas à me dire ce que vous aimeriez voir
vous dans endgame j'espère que cette
vidéo simple vous aura plu
si c'est le cas vous pouvez laisser
votre plus gros pouce bleus et activer
la cloche je vous encourage à faire un
tour sur mon ultime si vous souhaitez
soutenir mon travail me suivre sur
twitter ou tout simplement vous abonner
je suis prêt à enfin voir endgame et
body is ready compter sur moi pour vous
concocter des vidéos sur le film dès sa
sortie
bref c'était votre dévoué argot rock et
que le 'lion' earth soit avec vous
[Musique]